team up with people who believe in your
mission
it's critical it's everything
if you team up with the wrong people
even they have the skills you need your
business will not work
i got a great question from uh
youtube viewer
where is it linda linda has linda went
on a crazy i'm gonna watch every single
video evan has ever made i'm gonna
comment on everything so she left a
whole bunch of comments i love you linda
welcome to the channel
she wrote a question
when choosing to team up with uh
with somebody to promote a business
product or service how important is
finding someone who's like-minded in
business in your business mission or
your goals
linda this is so important this is
everything and it's not just finding
people to partner up with it's anybody
who has anything to do with your company
it's not just your partner it's your
suppliers it's your customers it's your
your your team
it's your investors it's everybody
if you bring the wrong people on board
your business
will not succeed
and it starts with you having a clear
understanding of what your mission is a
lot of people have no mission they don't
know what they stand for
they struggle to figure it out
if you've already if you're already
there that's that'll separate you
already from most people
when you're bringing on a team
you hire for that first if i need a
programmer for my business i look at my
company okay evancarwell.com i love
helping entrepreneurs right i believe in
entrepreneurs i believe that you could
change the world it's something i
believe in passionately i want to help
you do it i invest my time energy focus
on helping you guys do it making videos
like this where i'm not getting paid but
i love doing it it's what i stand for
i strongly passionately believe it and i
hope it comes through on these videos
if i'm hiring somebody for my company
you have to believe the same thing
if you don't believe in entrepreneurs if
you don't feel like you want to make a
difference and help business owners
you're not going to be a fit for my
company
and that's for everybody
if i'm bringing on a programmer because
i need to do a website i don't just need
a programmer who understands how to
write php or how to design a nice
looking website
i need somebody who believes in what
we're doing
who believes it just so strongly
there's a lot of reasons for it
the first is if you have different
values you're going to clash
you're going to clash they're going to
end up leaving you're going to firing
them it's just going to be a huge waste
of time
but more importantly
when the person you bring on as a
partner as an employee is an investor
whatever it is when they believe in what
you're doing
strongly just as passionately as you do
then you don't just have their brain you
have their heart you have their soul
they're not just coming to you and
working for you or working with you
because they're getting paid to do it
they're doing it because they love it
because they believe in what you're
doing and you're gonna get their best
ideas you're gonna get new things to
make your business even better they're
going to give you everything they have
as an example my programmer is a guy
named adis
adisa if you're watching this hey man
hope you're doing well
this has been with me for six or seven
years
this guy loves entrepreneurs
he loves it he's not just a programmer
he loves helping business owners when i
had events for entrepreneurs to to help
them with their company free events he
would come he would give advice he'd
meet them he'd learn from them
if i ever have a problem with my website
adis works just as hard as i do to fix
it
if my server goes down at three in the
morning adisa is waking up and he's
helping me fix it because he loves what
the business stands for and you can't
buy that
so if you're thinking about bringing on
a partner
that has to be a criteria start with
what you believe in why is this business
here what are you hoping to accomplish
what is your vision what is your goal
if you are bringing on the wrong people
if your employees are leaving or you're
firing them it's not their fault it's
your fault because you didn't clearly
explain to them what it is that you're
looking for you didn't have high enough
standards to say yeah you have the
skills but you don't believe in what
we're doing so i'm not going to hire you
or you were completely unclear on what
you wanted to do because if your only
goal is to make money you're not going
to make anything
you have to stand for something more you
have to stand for something bigger
and that makes you believe in it more it
helps you bring on the right customers
the right team the right partners the
right suppliers if your supplier doesn't
believe in what you're doing as much as
you do if they have a different vision
or goal
they're not going to bust their ass
excuse my french
to make sure that this thing happens i
hire people i work with companies i
bring people on board who love
entrepreneurship who love what we're
doing who believe in helping business
owners
because that's how we build a great
organization
so start
with a clear understanding of what it is
that you stand for and then everything
in your business
has to meet that standard if it doesn't
you keep searching until you find the
right person it'll take more time
but having standards and going for
quality takes time but when you get the
right people they're not going to leave
you
and they're going to give you everything
they have because they love what you're
all about
you're going to have more fun you're
going to make more money you're going to
have a greater impact too by the way
believe believe believe believe for
those of you watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below i'll do
more videos for you and i want to hear
what you have to think please leave a
comment underneath it makes me want to
do more i love seeing those comments
come in leave a question leave it below
i'll do a video response just like this
one thank you guys i love you guys i'll
see you soon